nous comme ap oui bonjour monsieur
le journal se gonfler le coût très bien
apporte loukoum deux ans fait partie des
trente chiens d'assistance qui sont
formés chaque année au centre
handi'chiens de vineuil ce golden
retriever sélectionné à huit semaines
pour sa joie et cette douceur vient de
passer un an et demi dans l'une des 55
familles d'accueil blésoise chargé de le
sociabiliser et de le pré éduqué il est
arrivé au centre en octobre dernier le
fonctionnement du centre ces deux de
prendre des chiens qui sont prêts
éduqués par des familles d'accueil et de
parfaire l'éducation des chiens pour
ensuite les remettre des personnes
handicapées des personnes à mobilité
réduite des dans des maisons de retraite
ou des enfants autistes au total look ou
monsieur est un entraînement pendant six
mois pour savoir répondre à plus de 50
commandes afin d'aider son futur maître
dans les gestes du quotidien
ramasser des carabins avril un placard
aboyer sur comment pour prévenir un
problème ou encore apprendre à reculer
dans les passages étroits un
apprentissage par le jeu auquel le chien
doit trouver du plaisir
alors notre principe d'éducation c'est
de renforcer tous des comportements que
positif que le chien va avoir est
d'ignorer les mauvais comportements donc
un comportement qu'on ignore chez le
chien obligatoirement s'éteindre
comportement renforce va ça va valoriser
le chien et ça va s'amplifier
l'éducation d'un chien durent deux en
écoute à l'association 15000 euros il
existe 4 centre handi'chiens en france
en mars prochain loukoum sera remis
gratuitement à son nouveau maître
après un stage d'adaptation de 15 jours
pour que se forment le couple maître
chien si ce golden ne répond pas
suffisamment aux exigences requises
il sera réformé et proposés à l'adoption